we are taking calls a lot of interest
from folks calling in today let's go at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 52 our caller may be a
local caller from the 774 area code 774
are you there yes I am hi David
hi how are you I'm good I'm from math
but in Providence now okay that's enough
all right so what I wonder is maybe it's
just because we're in southern New
England but everywhere I look I see
Bernie supporters
yet somehow Biden is still leading in
the primaries right you think that maybe
there is less of us and we're just
shouting louder yeah so I mean what you
have to understand about math I can
speak about Massachusetts Massachusetts
has a huge contingent of sort of what we
would call establishment Democrats
they're like more Kennedy types rather
than Bernie types if that makes sense
and they don't put signs out but they do
vote and they support people like Joe
Biden so I definitely think that when
you you know the that's that's the
reason why even though it feels like you
drive around and see Bernie signs in the
polls Joe Biden may still be doing well
in Massachusetts although I'll be honest
I haven't looked at Massachusetts
polling lately so I'm just taking your
word for it but yeah this is there's a
long history in Massachusetts of
center-left Democratic support and less
sort of like further left Democratic
support okay and am I the only one
that's a little scared that maybe if
Bernie doesn't get the nomination
there's gonna be kind of a revolt with
the young viewers like if there was a
Hillary that because they didn't get the
exact turnout they wanted that they're
just not really going to turn up because
they don't get the exact outcome they
want yeah I've talked about this and I
this is a concern of mine and I'm trying
not to fuel it by you know becoming
adversarial with people I've just been
trying to approach it from a more
positive perspective which is we should
all understand that during the primary
we advocate for and we support the
candidate that we believe most closely
aligns with our views and then not all
of those not everybody's going to get
the candidate they want in November of
2020 we have to turn out and make sure
we remove Donald Trump I'm trying to be
more positive rather than to address
any specific groups that I think might
stay home or vote Trump in some kind of
protest I hope it doesn't happen because
it could ruin the November of 2020
election exactly and I think maybe
Bernie did get the ticket there would be
record turnout like what there was for
Obama it's possible it's certainly I
think that Donald Trump more than
anything else may catalyze record
turnout and then if you combine that
with a particularly charismatic or
appealing candidate you could end up
with record turnout for multiple reasons
for sure yeah that orange idiot needs to
go right yes the tangerine what was that
I read the tangerine tumor as someone
referred to him okay thank you so much
for the call really great to hear from
you
yep thank you let's go next to where do
we want to go next
why not the five seven zero area code
let's talk to our caller from five seven
zero
what's your name are you calling from hi
hi David my name is Josh cane I'm from
Pennsylvania hey Josh what's up I'm a
hey I'm a big fan of your show David
because you're progressive I feel that
you take things from a positive
perspective and when you talk about
issues I feel that you don't read from
an ideological rulebook mmm so thank you
I thought thank you thank you for all of
your excellent analysis but uh I have a
simple question I'm sorry if it's been
asked before but I wanted to know if you
had to vote right now in the Democratic
primary who would you vote for Bernie or
Warren I've said I'm a Bernie Warren guy
okay great awesome um thank you David
all right thank you so much appreciate
the call